大家晚上好
我呢先汇报一下小米汽车的最新进展
小米SU7系列的话呢
算起来我们已经上市一年两个月啊
我们累计交付超过了25.8万辆
在上个月的话
我们交付了2.8万辆
这个数字的话呢
在20万以上的所有车型中
这一款车成为了销量冠军
下面的话我为大家发布小米预期
这是小米首款SUV
大家问的问题
第一个问题是这个YU7怎么念啊
YU7这样念
御风而行
这四个字来自于庄子的逍遥游啊
就是驾着风飞行啊
这个寓意特别好
所以叫YU7
那么YU7呢
定位成豪华高性能SUV
这就意味着预期不是一辆普通的
平庸的SUV
这是一款精心设计的豪华高性能的SUV
它既有优雅的造型
驾驶的愉悦感
同时还有空间的舒适度和豪华体验
我们来看一眼造型
它跟小米SU7一样
家族化的设计语言
但绝对不是SU7的简单拉高版
他不是SU7的简单拉高版
他是我们在SU7的基础上重新设计的
他优雅的设计风格
线条流畅且富有力量感
我们再来看一下它独特的豪车气质
不同凡响
还有跑车般的驾控体验
人车合一
说句实话
在这个价位
这样好看的SUV是非常非常罕见的
我们先看一下亮相视频
好我们YU7的话呢
车长5米
轴距3米
车宽两米
像这样的尺寸呢
是一款中大型的SUV
虽然外观看起来非常紧凑
而实际的空间呢
因为它是一款中大型的
SUV所以实际空间呢是非常大的
我们仔细来看一下啊
它的侧面低趴优雅
极具运动感
然后呢尾部呢
肌肉感十足
非常有力量
俯视的话
它的形面很立体
而且特别特别的饱满
好看吗好
我想跟大家分享一下
我们这么好看一辆车是怎么做出来的
首先
美首先来自于比例
就是比例好看
这个车才能好看
就像这个身材好看
这个人才会好看
好我们来看一下啊好
它好看的本质来自于3倍的轮轴比
2.1倍的轮高比
1.25倍的宽高比
同时它还有1.3倍的头身
比它修长的车头
这是百年汽车工业
沉淀下来的豪华设计
而且它从后视角看
极具肌肉感
自带宽体
还可以选配275毫米的后轮的宽胎
所以呢它整个特别特别有力量感
第二的话呢
美还来自于细节
首先我们来看一下这个水滴大灯
从功能上讲呢
支持了180度的超广角的照明
有很好的夜间视野
你仔细看的话呢
你发现它上半部分呢是镂空的
然后线路风道跟前舱盖打通
这是百万跑车才有的设计
然后呢光环尾灯呢也升级了
更适合SUV的造型
更加的简洁立体
更有力量感
在夜间的车流里面呢
也格外醒目
我们刚刚发布的时候大家有点不习惯
当你看习惯以后
你会觉得这个尾灯特别的好看
还有还有门把手
啊我们发布以后呢
很多人都问我们说啊
这个苏系的半隐藏式门把手挺好的
你们这次怎么又又退步了
其实没有
这是一个电动的内翻门把手
当你一靠近门把手就自动内翻了
当你离车或者坐到车里
哎它又回来了
这样的话呢
哎它既好看
风阻又小
我们来看一眼
好人一走近
它就自动弹开
然后当你坐到车里面以后
哎它又自动关闭
它是自电动的内翻的
这种设计
我不知道大家觉得好看吗
好好而且呢
在空气动力学方面的话呢
10组贯穿的风道
19个风口
在梳理全车的气流
好我们来看一些细节啊
像主动进气格珊
100档的智能开合
降低了18个counts
相当于增加了14公里的续航
尾部的凹流板
我们改了100轮
降低了10个counts还有
超大超帅的磅式大机盖
一体式设计啊
降低了两个抗次
所以呢我们改了多少个细节呢
改了40多处的风阻优化
像这么一款运动型的SUV
我们的风阻系数做到了0.245
这个在运动型的SUV里面
表现是非常非常突出的啊
它相当于续航增加了59公里啊
还有美呢
来自于色彩
SUV的形面更饱满更立体
我们在大自然里面
寻找有生命力的色彩
这样在光线的折射下呢
它的变化更加的丰富
也更加的好看
今天我们给大家介绍的第一款颜色
是什么呢
是宝石绿
这是一款高饱和度的颜色啊
我首先给大家介绍一下啊
这个包高饱和度的颜色
以前都只有跑车做
为什么呢
为什么你在大街上看到都是黑的
白的灰的
因为那三种颜色又好看又便宜
主要是便宜这个高饱和的颜
色贵在什么地方呢
各位想一想
这些车要在户外风吹雨打太阳晒
要10年20年不变色
大家想一想
这个做高饱和度的颜色有多复杂
所以每研发一款颜色
往往的周期都是13个月
周期特别特别长
所以这个颜色
绝对不是我们在电脑调色板里
改一下出来的啊
这个还是一个很复杂的研发过程
所以也只有做超跑的人
才愿意花那么多时间
做那么漂亮的颜色
投那么高的成本
大家还记得舒淇的海湾蓝
其实也很好看
也是高饱和度的
所以我们在做这些车的时候
特别愿意给大家推荐
那些特别好看的颜色
好同时我要给大家讲的是什么呢
这一款宝石绿
它的灵感来自于哥伦比亚的绿宝石
它的颜色饱和鲜艳
它有不可比拟的翠绿的色泽
晶莹剔透的质感
在光线下熠熠生辉
好
那么为了更好的还原绿宝石的质感
我们这次在工艺上
采用了双层色漆的工艺
这个双层的侧色漆的工艺
是怎么做的呢
光色罐用了三套
向外表面
我们先喷一层黄绿色的金属漆
再喷一层透明的珠光漆
在内表面呢
我们喷的是金属漆和珠光漆的混合漆
就喷这一个颜色
要三个罐子喷啊
其他的颜色
简单的都是用一个罐就行了
所以成本比一般的颜色贵了两倍以上
然后
所以这个做起来比大家想象的要困难
好这一款颜色呢
在阳光下看的时候特别好看
我们来看一下
这个在不同角度下欣赏宝石绿的话呢
它看起来就像宝石一样
光在形面上流转
影在漆面上流动啊
特别好看
我们在竹林也拍了一组
也很好看
今天的话呢
我们也给大家介绍第二款颜色
叫钛金属色
这个彰显豪华低调啊
在色漆里面
我们加入了粗颗粒的铝粉
让漆面具备金属独特的力量感啊
特别好看
啊同时的话呢
我还做了一款极为炸裂的颜色
熔岩橙
这个我特别特别喜欢这款颜色啊
但是呢我们SUV的形面更立体
更有质感和冲击力
所以的话呢
特别适合激情澎湃的年轻人
我也特别喜欢啊
所以也适合像我这样的年轻人啊
啊我们来看一下很漂亮
好啊加上上次的航母研会
整个预期呢
我们已经给大家介绍了4款颜色
后面还有5款啊
下次发布会再给大家慢慢介绍
都挺好看的
好我们来看一下它的内饰怎么样
先大家静静地看一会
是不有点像航空舱的感觉
然后呢我们的整个交互系统呢
增加了小米天气屏的全景显示
和后排的控制屏
带来了全新的视觉体验
好我们仔细看一下
这就是我们的天际屏
这个江湖有趣吧
好
各位仔细看
它不是一个简单的屏幕
它是一个集成的先进技术的高端投影
它有三块mini net的屏幕
通过全景曲面投影技术
反投到前风挡下的黑区
形成了1.1米超宽的显示
而且省视精度的话
也是超视网膜的高清显示
所以呢特别特别的好看
它是一个全景的曲面投影技
术啊它不是简单真的做了一块屏
而且呢我们的交互系统呢
也特别好用
符合直觉
像开车的时候
这个啊时速啊
导航啊这些信息一眼就能看清楚
这个副驾还可以显示音乐卡片
转向的时候
盲区影像就直接显示了是吧
一转向盲区影像就直接显示了
很方便
然后辅助驾驶的时候呢
自动切换成那个SR的路况信息
切换驾驶模式的时候呢
还可以显示动力空悬等信息
我们提供了五类的信息卡片
大家还可以自动的组合好
像这样先进的技术
我有一个视频来展示
小爱同学
我想回家
啊啊
好我们的内饰呢
不仅有科技感
还有豪华感
我们采用了双曲环绕的设计
它的形面呢简洁饱满
仪表台很薄
视野呢特别特别通透
用料呢也特别的豪华
人接触的地方呢
100%软包覆的
而且呢我们的材料呢
还是婴儿可以直接接触的
接触的
这种材料获得了国际的一级认证
所以整个材料啊触感呢都特别好
这个空间呢也特别大啊
前排的空间我们用的1.88米的假人
当你坐进去的时候
头顶空间还有100毫米
这个比model y和卡宴都要大不少
而且呢座椅的风格
这一次呢我们调的是豪华舒适型的
因为初期我们调的偏硬偏运动型的
偏路感型的
这边呢偏豪华型的好
我们还搭载了零重力座椅
通过把腿部和靠背的角度
调整成120多度
科学分配身体的压力
来提升乘坐的舒适感
而且呢
我们还配了10点10点式的按摩啊
特别适合停车的时候休息一下
或者中午在车里睡个午觉什么的啊
好我们的主驾的零重力座椅呢
有12层结构
更厚更软
更有支撑力
其中零压感的海绵
让短途乘坐呢更舒服
高密度的记忆海绵
它的支撑力好
久坐不累
而且全车的座椅都是Nappa包覆
它的触感极其的细腻
谈到零重力座椅呢
这也是这几年啊
我们国家的新能源汽车卷起来了啊
这个豪车都还没开始卷
我们已经全卷零重力座椅了
好大家坐零重力座椅的时候
往往都是放在后排或者副驾
而我们的车呢
放在前排
因为我们发现很多人开车的时候
在车上休息都习惯坐在主驾位上
所以这一次呢
我们特别设计了前排
主副驾都是零重力座椅
欢迎大家呢到店体验啊
这不是一辆MPV
这是一辆自己开的车
所以主驾我们一定要设计的特别舒服
像这样的设计
其实在SUV里是很少见的
一般放后排或者副驾
我们在想是吧
这个车是你的
你不想开得舒服一点吗
好
所以呢我们的虽然是运动的姿态
但是我们的内部空间有惊喜
比如说后排一样是一米88的假人
头部空间有77毫米
膝部空间73毫米
都比model y和卡宴好
所以大家完全不用担心好吗
好
好后排的座椅也是同级一流的
可坐可躺
电动无级调节
能调35度的范围
他们说堪比豪车的座椅的舒服度啊
这个我就不跟哪个豪车比
了好吗
好
很舒服的啊
这个很舒服好
我们的这个内饰呢
有三种颜色
有松石灰
它是绿灰双色的
有珊瑚橙
还有木影蓝
有三种颜色啊
谈到这里呢
我们再看看储物空间啊
首先
我要给大家推荐的是这个磅式前机盖
啊超大啊啊
听我的同事介绍
这是量产车里最大规模的
它的面积有3.11平方米
做到了无分缝
这对制造要求是很高的
跟整车的型面浑然一体
非常的漂亮
而且这个是一个电动的是吧
前机盖啊
打开以后里面有141升的超大前备箱
然后呢整车的储物容积呢
有1,970升
非常的大好
我们把大家常用的场景也捋了一下
比如说两个人去郊外骑行
带两辆自行车和行李
周末三个人去滑雪
三套滑雪板带行李
四个人自驾游
带很多的箱子和行李
都可以搞得定啊
都可以搞得定
所以聊到这里的话呢
我还要最后聊一聊呢
预期的设计理念
它完全遵循了
我们小米汽车的设计理念
就是回归设计的本质
寻找符合直觉的美
符合自然的美
用一句话总结就是
做经得起时间考验的设计
下面的话呢
我们请我们的首席设计师李田园
通过视频方式给大家介绍一下
如果给你一张白纸
不管多少年过去
多少款车过去
你依然能够画出小米汽车的家族符号
这些符号是属于这台车的
它也属于时间
喜欢我们小米汽车的设计吗
喜欢
好预期作为一款豪华高性能的SUV
下面呢我们聊一聊性能
它的性能呢也非常非常的出色
它的零百的加速呢
3.23秒它的最大马力呢
690匹它的最高时速呢
253公里每小时
这在SUV里是非常非常出色的啊
我们比一下啊
像model y的性能版
performance performance的版本啊
它的零百呢是3.7秒
像Macan EV Turbo
这款96.8万的就是将近一百万的车啊
它的零百呢是3.3秒啊
预期的顶配呢是3.23秒
所以这个成绩啊
在SUV里是非常非常出色的
那么这么好的性能
它背后呢是强大的电机
然后呢小米超级电机
V6S的plus
这个是在V6S的基础上
转速提升到22,000转
它的扭距和功率也升级了
性能呢变得更好
同时它有豪华的底盘配置
兼顾了运动和舒适性
然后呢
整车呢
标配了连续阻力的可变减震器
精准匹配了路况需求
快速的调节阻力力
能够适应山路
城市高架和烂路各种各样复杂的工况
然后呢还有B4的双枪空簧
它有五档的高度调节
最大的调节范围达到75毫米
最高呢的离地间隙达到了222毫米
而且呢它可以快速调节空环的刚度
最大的高低刚度差超过了40%
在保持路感的同时
可以做到更加的舒适
所以呢我们整个底盘系统呢
是极其豪华的配置
它的制动能力呢
同样很出色啊
从100公里每小时刹到0啊
最短的制动距离呢
33.9米这个呢和保时捷911相当
这是百万跑车机的自动能力
而且呢还提供了四重自动
勇于的安全机制
带来了更稳定更安全的自动能力啊
好我们总结一下
这个YU7呢
有三个版本
和model y的版型是一样的
有单电机的后驱版
也有双电机的四驱版和高性能四驱版
三个版本好
它的性能呢都非常好
都有V6S plus的小米超级电机
那么Max的零百呢
达到了3.23秒
在SUV里非常强大
而且全系标配的固定卡钳
和四重荣誉的刹车
刹车安全系统
它的底盘都很好
都标配了连续阻力的可变减震器
所以大家仔细看看
你需要哪一档的动力啊
平时家用的话哎
这个挺好的是吧
如果预算还可以的话
直接上顶配
它的性能很好
当然呢这个Pro版的话呢
也相当不错
它有是吧连续阻力的减震器
也有空簧
而且呢又是四驱
它的通过性和脱困性
那包括性能都很不错
所以呢这张图建议大家拍下来
可以仔细看一下
就关于我们的动力啊
这个版型
跟那model y的设置是完全一样的
好
续航
对一款纯电的SUV来说
续航尤其重要
因为开SUV嘛
大家都经常愿意跑远路
但是呢从汽车研发的角度上来说
续航是最贵的配置
所以看车贵不贵
先看续航
因为电池包特别贵
电池包占了整车成本40%上下
所以这个续航是最贵最贵的配置
那么
大家知道
预期的标准版的续航有多少吗
大家冷静看一下 835公里
这是标准版的续航啊
以这个续航能力呢
我的同事们做了很多的比较啊
它是它是
所有中大型纯电SUV的续航第一啊
哪怕你拥有更大的电池包
也未必比我们跑得远
因为有时候电池包太大以后
它也变得更重
而且这个续航除了电池包以外
它还很跟很多很多因素相关啊
我们可以比一下
你比如说电板
看100度电跑700公里啊
EQS 111度电跑742公里
所以我们要找到一个最佳的平衡
然后做了835公里
那么835公里
我们搭配的是多大的电池呢
我们起步就是96.3度电啊
将近100度电
我们起步就是将近100度电的大电池包
这个成本非常的贵
好啊
大家知道我们有三个版本啊
那我们看一下四驱的纯电续航
因为往往动力越大啊
续航会越差
因为它跑得快
它是需要消耗更多的动力的
好我们来看一下
你会发现
我们四驱的纯电SUV的续航也不错
能做多少呢
770公里
它也是四驱纯电SUV的续航冠军
好model y的四驱它的续航是多少呢
是吧它的续航是719公里
他们其实已经做得很好了
我们是770啊
所以呢我还是要再划一次重点
哪怕是四驱的SUV
那个预期依然是续航第一啊
所以我总结一下这个我们是吧
我们三个版本
那个全部都是大电池
那个全系都是超长续航
而且全系呢800伏碳化硅的高压平台
而且我们的Max版呢
还是5.2C的
充电15分钟能最大补能620公里
所以呢充电的效率呢
也非常非常的快
好那个我们简单的比一下充电啊
这个model y大概是吧10%到80%需要27分钟
这个电买看21分钟
我们12分钟
所以我们的充电效率是非常快的
好这就是呢
我们三个版本的是吧
那个电池
那个续航和充电效率
你看这个835公里
96.3度电的铁锂
这个是770公里啊
96.3的铁锂这
个呢是101.7度电的三元锂
760公里啊
但是它主要是为了更高的性能
和更强大的动力啊
所以YU7的这款纯电的SUV
具备超强的产品力
全系大电池包
全系是吧超长续航
全系800伏的高压
所以呢这些都是很顶的配置啊
所以聊到这里
聊到这里
我想跟他说
预期之所以如此的强大
背后有非常多的创新技术
今天的时间很短
我呢就给大家讲三点
第一个
第一个然后
预期也采用的是摩德纳的技术架构
跟SU7一样
我们在继承了SU7的优势上
做了大幅度的修改和增强
比如说铠甲龙式车身全面升级
这个全面升级以后内容很多
我讲三点第一点
啊我们长车头带来的
这个车头的吸能空间
就是你碰撞的时候
有个吸能溃缩的吸能空间
我们做到了659毫米
然后比model y多了100毫米的吸能空间
这个能够承受更大的溃缩力啊
第二个
底部我们增加了1,500兆帕的横梁
用来降低电磁包是吧
经常遇到石子刮坏的可能性
增加了个1,500兆帕的横梁
第三点我们电磁包底部
也用了Ultra同款的防弹涂层
来进一步保护电池包的安全
还有个最重要的
我们数据上用了2千兆帕的潜艇钢
这一次
我们预期用了2,200兆帕的小米超强钢
这是目前量产的最高强度的热成型钢
好它强在什么地方呢
我们用在什么地方啊
首先我们用在侧横梁上
就是四门的防撞梁
因为有时候侧撞的时候
乘员舱啊
侧撞的时候离乘客很近
一致是被动安全的难点
我们这次呢
用了2,200兆帕
用在四门的防撞梁上
前门的承载能力提升了50%
后门的承载能力提高了37%
有效的提升了侧碰的安全性
所以这个材料科技非常重要
第二个
我们在a柱b柱里面用了6根热气胀管
也是2,200兆帕的小米超强缸
能跟车身配合在一起
形成了一个防滚架的模型
这就是我们借鉴了这个防滚架的原理
它能够在应付恶劣的场景下
更好的保护乘员舱的结构
大家了解这个a柱和b柱吧
在里面装了6根热气胀管
形成了一个内嵌式的防滚架
的这个结构
啊好
有什么好处呢
我们来看一下
a柱的承载力提升35%
b柱提升了70.5%
所以它的强度得以大规模的提升
那么这个这是怎么做到的呢
我们的工艺用了一种叫热气藏工艺
就用高压气体
像吹气球一样
把这个2,200兆帕的材料
在模具里面吹成你所需要的形状
好再嵌再嵌入到a柱和b柱里
这个这个技术还是蛮难的啊
这么高强度的钢材要吹成这个形状
用的热气胀的工艺啊
好这个材料的话呢
是和大学的科研团队
育才堂呢合作研发的啊
所以呢材料科技呢非常关键
那么这个超强钢有多强呢
啊我让同事们做了个实验
用251公斤的金属球去撞击这个防撞梁
我们原来的防撞梁不是1,500兆帕的
换到2,200兆帕的时候我们看一下
哎我们就是用这么大一个铁球
250多公斤啊
去砸这个防撞梁
我们砸一下
各位 1,500的已经裂开了
你看2,200兆帕的没裂
所以我们这个龙式车身的话呢
铠甲龙式车身的话呢
高强度钢和铝合金的占比达到了90.2%
车身的扭转刚度呢
超过了47,000牛米每度
这个在SUV里面是表现极其优秀的啊
然后全场景的被动安全的性能测试啊
多达50多项啊
完全覆盖了CNCAP
和中保研的所有的碰撞测试
所以呢我们呢
在过去我们的初期的产品里
在所有的权威机构的碰撞测试里面
我们都拿到了最高分啊
好下面呢
我们讲第二项技术
电子电器架构
因为这个智能电动汽车啊
智能占的比例越来越高
而且也越来越复杂
这也是我跟大家讲
为什么小米做车优势之所在
就是我们做电子已经做了15年啊
好我们给大家介绍一个
我们的自研的产品
叫什么呢
叫四合一的控制器
这就是把汽车里面的辅助驾驶域
智能座舱域
整车控制域和通讯模块
四个盒子全部合并在一起
高度集成
它相当于几十个功能合在一起了
相当于一个中央大脑
你可以把它理解成一个小服务器
好原来在车里呢
就是搞了一堆的盒子
好把它全部集成在一起了
那么原来
或者今天的主流的结构是怎么样的呢
我专门摆了一套
就是搞了一堆盒子
好这就是我们的
可以吧
所以一比你就知道它首先一个特点
它的体积大规模缩小了
而且它减重
它从原来的五公斤降低到3.6公斤
而且把这些域全部合并以后呢
它的能效大幅度优化
通讯性能也大幅度提高
而且控制机的数量呢
也大幅度减少
我举一个小例子啊
比如说哨兵模式
原来刷屏模式为什么耗电呢
他跨好多个域
才能把视频内容上传云端
你才能看得到在手机上
好现在的话呢
它的通讯链路被极大的精简
它都是在一个域里就完成了
相当于在一个域里完成了啊
相当于在一个盒子里完成了
然后呢
它的视频信号两步就可以上传云端
整个功耗降低了40%
所以整个四合一带来的好处
是非常非常之多的
而且的话呢
我们的座舱的Soc
用了第三代骁龙8的移动平台
4纳米的平台啊
像这个高算力的旗舰平台
让系统呢极其流畅
所以我们的整个车机开机快
应用启动快
OTA升级也快
最快15分钟就能完成OTA
这可能是行业今天最快的OTA
有时候有的车一升级需要一两个小时
所以升级很慢
第二个的话
这个四合一的控制器啊
它的辅助驾驶模块的算力也很恐怖
它是搭载了最新的Nvidia的
英伟达的硕平台啊
4纳米的先进工艺
7百top值的算力是极其惊人的
而且呢还有先进的通讯技术
有双5G的并行通讯网络
UWB的进场通讯
还有Wifi 7
你在车里玩手机
连接车内热点的时候
可以提速超过80%
所以把最新的科技全部用了一遍
啊
而且呢我们新一代的电子电器架构
经过了非常严苛的可靠性测试
这个耐久测试
采用的是行业标准两倍以上的标准
进行严格测试的
所以呢
这是我给大家介绍的第二项技术
四合一的控制器
好第三项呢是小米辅助驾驶
这一次呢
我们全套硬件都是高端配置
我简单给大家介绍一下啊
算力呢是700TOPS的这个
这是英伟达最先进的和最新的啊
专为大模型时代而生的
我们搭载硕也是全球首批第二个呢
激光雷达
它的探测距离达到200米
进一步提高了辅助驾驶的安全性
在暗光环境下
在异形障碍物的这个识别里面
激光雷达有明显的优势
还有4D毫米波雷达
它的分辨度和识别距离都提升了
在一些复杂的场景
比如说跟车
当前车急刹车的时候
它有更好的预警能力
在雨天雾天恶劣天气的时候
即使肉眼看不见的时候
也能更好的感知交通状态
所以有4D毫米波雷达
哪怕摄像头
我们也应用了我们手机相机的技术
做了LD的镀膜
能更好的抑制逆光
炫光产产生的视觉干扰
整个画质更加清晰透彻啊
这个比如说这一张
这个人完全看不见
这个人非常的已经清楚了不少吧
好
这个全套的硬件呢
都是非常非常高端的
这个包括700托普斯的算力激光雷达
4D毫米波雷达
11个高清摄像头
还有其中7个做了LED镀膜
还有12个超声波雷达
那么这一套配置进一步提高
了安全性
而且成本也非常非常贵
那么是吧
为了进一步提高辅助驾驶的体验
我们全系标配
所以我们的入门版就是带激光雷达
带4D毫米波雷达
带700T的算力的
全是今天是吧最高端的配置之一啊
好讲到这里呢
这就是我们今天给大家介绍的预期
我简单的总结一下
作为一台豪华高性能的SUV
全系标配了非常强大的配置
第一个全部标配的大电池
超长续航
全部标配了全景是吧
小米天气屏的全景显示
全系标配了700T的算力
全系标配了激光雷达
全系标配了连续阻力可变减震器
就是超豪华的底盘
好那我们再看一眼
它有三个版型是吧
标准版续航835公里
然后96.3度电的电
激光雷达
7百top的算力
包括连续阻力减震器
像这样的配置拿出来
可能是其他公司的车型里面的
Pro版还是Max
还是Ultra
我们在内部也反复讨论说
我们要不也跟大家对齐叫Max版吧
其实在这个讨论里面
我还是希望我们小米保持真诚
他就叫标准版好吗
就是
只不过是我们的标准版是超大杯的
大家理解了吗
好来我们看Pro版增加了什么
最重要的是增加了双电机四驱和b
是双腔空簧
就是它的动力通过性
脱困能力大幅度提升了
大家理解了吧
那Max呢
它是高性能四驱
它全部是顶配
有非常多豪华配置
我今天呢就不展开讲了
为了让大家加深印象
我们比一
下model y啊
为什么比model y呢
因为反正在初期出来之前
model 3打遍天下没敌手
就不要谈model y了啊
model y是全球销冠啊
很厉害很厉害
好
这个
因为model y也是三个型号
我们就一个一个型号对一下
让大家建立一个印象啊
我们来看一下全球销冠
model y的标准版
就是它所谓的后驱版
这个YU7呢
零百是5.88秒
他是5.9秒
这两家的动力差不多
而我们用了96.3度电
835公里的续航
他们只有62.5度电
590公里的续航
大家知道差了多少吗
差了34度电啊
差了340多公里的续航
这好像高了好几个档次啊
这个各位啊
简单翻译一下
贵了好几万啊
第二个预期还标配了天际屏激光雷达
连续阻力可变减震器800伏
还有各种各样我还没有讲的豪华配置
反正model y定价26.35万
我觉得y我觉得预期看这些配置
至少应该贵个六七万哈
这个具体的价钱呢
等我们啊7月份发布的时候再讲好吗
但是我看到网上有很多人揣测
哎呀这个雷总肯定定个19万九啊
不要这么想
不可能的好吗
这个这个
这个配置啊
以model y定价
没有三十几万绝对下不了台的啊
好我们再来看一下
啊Pro版对它的长续航全能驱动
啊他们的动力依然差不多
但是呢他们的电池只有78度电
我们是96度电
大概大了20度电啊
续航呢多了50公里
更重要的
我们还配了空簧
所以这个配置也比他们强很多
那么他们的性能版
model y的性能版呢
也是78度电
我们101度电
它的性能版只有615公里的续航
我们760 所以这个动力啊
续航豪华配置
我觉得我们的Max版呢
是真的非常非常领先啊
具备压倒性优势
好说到这里的话呢
这个我们的YU7的发布呢
就快结束了啊
预期呢将于7月份正式上市
如果大家特别特别关心预期的话
现在就下载小米汽车的APP
可以提前预约咨询
展车我们马上就陆续到店
等到店以后
我们的产品专家会邀请大家到店体验
好吗
啊我曾经也想向同行学习搞个小定
但是我们的GTM
我们的操盘手担心太折腾大家了
所以我们就不小定了
如果你们有兴趣呢
欢迎大家在小米汽车APP里面
是吧留下联系方式
我们的产品专家呢会联系你好吗
好
好下面就进入最重要的模式
用热烈的掌声欢迎预期上台
哦哦哦
the victory
好看吗是不是太漂亮了
大家欣赏一下我们的宝石绿
很漂亮啊
这个首先我们看一下它的这个
这个大灯啊
非常非常的漂亮
上半部分是镂空的
前机盖是棒式的铝制大机盖啊
而且这个风道呢
是跟前舱盖的风道是连通的
然后呢我们来看一下
整个车的姿态
非常的低趴啊
很有力量感
很有冲劲
而且也是黄色的卡钳啊
固钳整个颜色呢
在灯光下啊
熠熠生辉
非常非常的漂亮
好
聊到这里的话呢
我还有一个小的消息啊
我们1:18的合金车模已经上架啊
它的四门两盖都可以打开
做工非常非常的精致
听说我们的车模比车还难抢啊
定价呢
定价多少钱
599啊有宝石绿和钛金属两款颜色
还有礼盒版和至尊版啊
想要的朋友现在就可以开始买了啊
这个王他们已经上架了好吗
好
我还给大家推荐一下
我们小米的精英驾驶的课程
高阶驾驶培训
四年前呢
我刚刚开始做车的时候啊
我们就给所有的高管
安排了一次驾驶培训
其实参加完那次培训以后
我发现啊
我开了30多年车
原来我还是不太会开车
因为我从来没有一脚踩死过刹车
是吧
我们以前学车的大家都教你点刹
其实遇到紧急状况的最好是一脚踩死
可是当你所以那一次呢
我们学了一脚地板油
一脚刹车
紧急变线
我觉得这些能力提高以后呢
使我重新开始认知怎么开车好
所以呢我们专门设计
把我们内部的课程拿出来想
希望更多的车主呢
学习这些高阶驾驶技巧啊
就是从理论到实践来提高驾驶能力
比如说加速自动紧急变线练习
比如说你能不能一脚刹车
刹停在锥筒前面
你能不能在最短的时间
加速到一定的速度
而且呢你应该怎么学习变线
第二个课程呢
叫绕桩练习
哎你怎么躲人躲东西
然后怎么绕桩
然后第三个训练呢
就是低幅路面的驾驶培训
比如说下雨天下雪天
冰面路滑
你应该怎么开车
所以为什么呢我
们这一次在预期的三个版型里面
专门增加了两款
我们原来初期只有一款四驱
只有两款
四驱主要是脱困性能
就是在低辅路面上的脱困
好啊除了这三个培训以外呢
啊为了提升课程的有趣性呢
我还让他们提供了金卡纳的练习
金卡纳呢
就是用很多锥筒来摆线路的
一种小型场地障碍赛
就是你要用加减速
连续变向过弯等技巧快速的跑完全程
然后在这种比赛的环境里面呢
提高你对极限状况的响应
来提高你的驾驶能力啊
这个学完以后会非常非常有帮助啊
好这段时间呢
我都在考察各种各样的培训项目啊
但是这类的培训呢
其实同行也有定价呢
都非常的贵啊
它的成本也特别特别贵
所以呢后来呢
我们定价呢1,999
这个5月27号开启报名
在陆多个城市陆续开始培训
首先面向小米的车主
还有锁单的准车主
当然啊
我们的团队已经做了精心的准备
我依然担心呢
他们的经验不足
所以我为这个培训
也会提供一个特别的优惠
来邀请一些车主帮我们测试
那么这个优惠幅度有多大呢
首批的1万人全部免费
所以如果大家有兴趣的话
在5月27号开始培训
因为车教练场地都是我们提供的
然后我们也会跟大家从理论到实践
来教大家怎么把车开好
怎么了解车的这个边界好吗
好啊
如果我们这个培训课程中
有什么需要改进的
随时希望大家在社区里给我们提意见
我们会把这些课程改的
越来越好好吗
好
好到这里的话呢
我们的预期的发布就要结束了
我想跟大家聊一聊
预期呢是为谁设计的
我觉得这个问题呢蛮重要的
其实我在设计预期的时候
我们思考非常非常多
这辆车我们做了三年多时间
我们是为哪些人设计的呢
我们是为那些
不能容忍平庸的人设计的
是为那些
始终走在时代前列的人设计的
就是无法容忍平庸
所以我们希望做一个有性格
有态度的车
那么这群人
他们是一个什么样子的人呢
我用几段话来描述一下
他们经历风雨
依然对生活充满热情
他们乐观豁达
始终保持着自信进取的个性
还有无论世界如何纷繁
他们都能做到从容不迫
举重若轻
我们的预期呢
就是为那些先进的时代精英打造的
先进的SUV
今年呢是小米15周年
我想和大家分享一句我特别喜欢的话
我曾经五年前引用过
叫疾风知劲草
路遥知马力
今天的小米
肯定有很多很多不完美的地方
肯定有很多很多不如意的地方
在下个5年
我们承诺大家
我们会用更坚实的成长
来交出一份更好的答卷
好今天的发布会到此结束
谢谢大家
谢谢